yes welcome to the video for the new round of
the Dortmund Chess Days 2012 and the
ninth is also the last
round, so the tournament is over and
yes we have two shared winners, not
particularly surprising that more than
one made it after five
players were tied on points before  In the
last round and according to the rating,
Fabiano Caruana from Italy won the tournament.
I don't think it was entirely unexpected after he
achieved this super important win against Kramnick yesterday and was
certainly
able to compete today in the best possible mood. He won with
black against Matteo Spartel
I'll also show the game afterwards because it
was the decisive game for winning the
tournament. The cos winner is Serge
kajakin, who won today against
Jan Gustafsson, who certainly
played the worst tournament
that he
can probably remember with a total of -  6 so
six defeats and three draws kayakin,
like Kana, has a
total result of + 3 i.e. three
more games won than lost, wi kayakin did
n't suffer a defeat so three
wins and six draws and kaana even
won four games he started
badly  a draw and, um,
then a defeat against ponom
marov and then really got rolling
so the two of them
won the tournament together, which also means that
akadi neidic and Peter Lego
played a draw, but the game was
a very tough fight at times
I thought akadi could  Maybe
win with a sea pawn, so
win not in the sense that he would have
had a winning position but would have had a
chance of winning, but the draw
ended with an original
permanent chess at the end and
Russia Ponomov also played a draw against
Daniel
Friedmann, also an exciting game.
I actually thought that  Daniel
would have had a lot of difficulties at times but
in the end it was still a draw and yes
a really nice game at the end
maybe a bit forgiving I
don't know I think Kramnick will still be
disappointed with his
performance he won the
last round against Georg Meer again with that
yes also falls back to a negative result
in the end then 1 for the
German
yes kramnick was able to create a nice combination at the end
and
yes it was even
played to checkmate checkmate in the open field very
nice final picture yes good I'm
introducing Caruana's game because that  In the
end it was crucial for the
tournament victory, let's take a look at Bartel
opens D4 and
kwana defends himself here with
Grünfeld, which he often
plays not as an exclusive
response, but he plays it very often
and Bartel is now playing what is
perhaps the main variation of next to
d5 and then
E4  the classic retort here
against Grünfeld who takes possession of the center
Bishop G7 yes and now
he decides on the variant with knight F3
C5 and rook B1
which is a bit out of fashion
so today people actually try
with the very old one  Variant,
so to speak, on bishop C4 something to
try or with bishop E3 ​​these
variants are a little more
fashionable these days the problem is a bit of
the move here tower
B1 the idea is that the bline
takes the bline immediately here
and then black makes it a little more difficult to
develop  The problem with the variant is
the following: black is now playing here
castling Bishop
E2 C sch DC Schle D so black
also has alternatives but that is the
absolute main variant Queen A5 Chess
and there are really hundreds of
games with the continuation Bishop D2
the victim so black can now
grab the pawn on A2 and then riert knows
yes and that is now the
starting position of an incredible
theoretical geäel that a normal person
can no longer remember at all,
i believe in the
books by Grandmaster
Boris avruck that were published a few months ago or at the end of last year  I hope I'm saying
half correctly from Israel about
Grünfeld also recommended this variant for
Black and I don't know how
many pages that is, but it's a huge
piece of paper and it comes to the
end that Black somehow holds up here with a
miserably long variant
So some I don't know what
it was continuous chess or yes so it's
terribly exhausted and it
seems that I don't know much here has to be
treated with caution statement but that's how
it is at the moment Bartel now has the move in the
position after Queen A5
Played Queen D2, which has
actually been considered harmless for years
but was recently tried out
against
Caruana, yes black, now the
queen is not a big choice and now
Caruana plays move E6. Just a few weeks ago
he already had the position with
black against Radjabow  and the rook had
moved D8, maybe he was simply
surprised by the white choice because that's
really rarely tried anymore,
this exchanging of queens and yes, it went
like that here, I'll just show it briefly without
us wanting to go deep now
E5 yes, nice little trick
black  plays H6 now couldn't
take on d5 because of the pinning move bishop
C4 and looks stupid
came H6 bishop C4 king H8
wheel G5 rook D1 yes and this position
is much better for white,
a small miracle that Rab did
n't win in this position  v all
because something like that e plays very powerfully once he
has the opponent on the slack
he usually wins too so
carana played the opening really very
badly four weeks ago it was
at the Memorial in
so in this respect Bartel's choice has to go
a bit further in principle  have been
motivated by this game but
now comes the mysterious Kana
just now plays here E6 which is simply the
main move or B6 it leads
to the same position Rade and B6 so
black and just wants to put the bishop C8
to B7 places completely natural
development so he  Now just play
what is normal here and notice that
is how things continue now so Bartel
now plays tower C1 bishop B7
and here is actually the main move that was
played the most is the move bishop
B4 tower D8 continues bishop B5 yes
and then have  We have a game that's
giving Black a bit of a headache at the moment is this
knight here who can't just
go to C6, so White is trying
to limit it and still has
this idea of ​​rook C7 in the position, now of
course bishop E7 is also threatening
rook catch, so this position should
be roughly balanced, the
results are completely okay for Black,
but that's actually how it
goes normally, and not so that this
position is now the big hit for
white, so it's not entirely clear what
white
wants to play with it  Bartel then at the end
here the move rook C7 which
looks interesting immediately attacks the bishop
on B7 and the black now has no
choice he has to capture the pawn here
and has first won the big central pawn
yes and now it's getting really
weird now here comes it  Move knight G5
and it's just bad,
in that sense
White's preparation here is a complete mystery to me because if
he's already playing it like that and caroana has
already had the variation,
um he could have expected the variation like that
and if you  then practically
immediately um if you make a mistake it's
really strange so what knows should
play here should be played by Kuana himself
after the game is bishop
B4 now attacks the rook on F8
and rook saves itself and then rook C1
so white has for that  Pawns have good
control on the c-file and m yes that
should probably be balanced in several ways
so a possible continuation would be A5
bishop
E7 rook E8 bishop B5 yes at first
you think black would lose the exchange
but has the tricky move
knight
A6 bishop  E8 knight
C7 bishop takes f7 king takes rook
C7 and yes now you can count it out,
it is now materially the same and the
position should really
be about the same so there is nothing to worry about for
black but white is still okay
in the game as I said  he now has
the move knight G5 and I find it
really mysterious because the
computer immediately shows that white is
bad, so I don't know what
he has prepared, maybe he
just swapped moves somehow or something like that,
black moves the attacked
bishop to the beautiful one  Square
D5 Bishop
B4 now grabs the rook which is
moving away,
yes and here comes the second
mistake, so if we had
at least taken on f7 now, I think
he still has it, well, it's not nice, but
he can still do it, he can still
play it  Tower D7 for example and then the
moving tower
FC1 is very very very tricky because
bishop B5 is now the idea so if
black now takes it comes bishop B5
and now the rook is on D8 a
bit strange ca
n't move away anywhere and be taken by red
um  yes, bishop D4 should be the best
move if black now
takes rook C7 on C7, the problem is that these
bishops are already UPS no, I did
n't want to do it that way, these bishops
already have a decent effect and
what should black play now to get up  To
play for a win if he runs here
then
things can get really unpleasant here after a while,
so the best thing to do in this
position is simply to take the pawn here
and
you then get this strange
position where black simply has one pawn
more but white still has a certain amount
Activity, e.g. something like this that white can
continue to fight because he
has a really good rook on C6 that has
options here, the pawn is
just UPS no, not like that, my
God, no, that's what I wanted to do, the
pawn is weak so white can
still do it here  Of course, fighting is
clearly worse but better than the
game
it was in the game instead of taking on
f7 he played bishop B5 and
that is also mysterious because black
now simply has A6 and yes what has he
overlooked now when white now moves the bishop
away again  Then Black can
simply develop further here and is standing
so that's close to winning, so
bishop C4 is really bad and
he ended up making knight F7 but
now black has the [ __ ] settlement
B5 so just let the
rook here attack  is to stand up
because now this nice move is done with
a fork and on a
lot of not only the two but also the D8
knight is hanging, so in
horror all the white pieces
are hanging so to speak and the only thing that
now averts immediate exit is the
nemen on G7 he also has  played yes and
now you ask yourself how to save,
you actually have to move these two pieces
and now a completely crazy
position has been created where this knight
on the 8 is really a real
joke, it has absolutely no field
and is completely replaced here
by the bishop
dominates here and he just has to
hold on to his knight here, so it's
a complete catastrophe, this
opening position for white, yes, and now it
's just important to
keep your nerve because it's clear that Black is
now winning here, so
keep your nerve and show good technique  and
yes the black one doesn't disappoint us here
plays B4 and fixes D with the
pawns on A2 and you get that
too now that's the
problem rook C1 flup and there the
pawn is gone yes and the b pawn is very
fast is directly
supported so here  White can now
only row a bit Rook C6 came
B5 first secures the b-pawn Black
is in no hurry because it's a nice trick White
can't take E6 now because
Black can take Rook and
then the nice move Knight
C5 yes the back rank is pretty embarrassing
here for  white even more material so
knight E6 doesn't play in this
position and made H4 to
at least remove the basic row, the basic
mat
B3 bishop
A3 alternatively you could take bishop A3 here,
but that leads to the game position we
immediately see bishop A3 and now black has
the strict move  Knight
B4 and that's the soft club in the
position white can't take now
on B4 because then the pawn just
goes through, very stupid so
you can't take there and
yes what should he play it depends yes that one
it hangs that one and yes the door hangs
He also made knight E6
King G8 yes and now white
really loses house and court
these two pieces are still hanging and the pawn yes white
gave
up a bit
yes a
bit disappointing actually
this final round performance here from the
white player I think
a lot  More can be done, but maybe it's
a bit worn out due to the strenuous tournament.
Yes, kawana won the game here and
yes, he's the tournament winner. I
think overall, he deserves to win four
games in the field. They're very
strong, especially winning against Kramnik
in the penultimate round, so it
was yesterday  Extremely strong, great
performance, actually always
had something in the game and then
won it pretty confidently because it's
a well-known phenomenon genes, the
strongest players can get a good position,
some but not all of them win,
so the one that can really be turned around
was already very strong  In
principle, purely formally, this was the
game that won the tournament
because it was in the final round today,
but the key game was
certainly the win against Kramn
yesterday. Without that game, the chance would
n't have been there today, so a strong
performance from Kuana  He's only
20 years old, so you can
definitely expect a lot and
Kayin, as the co-winner, is also in his early
20s, so the two youngest players in
the list of participants won
the tournament. It's also a bit of a sign of the times, and the tournament circus is going on  yes, the
same
distance, I think tomorrow is the first
round in Biel with, among others, Karlsen
and Nakamura. I think
we can look forward to some interesting chess.
I won't be making daily videos
because it
's very time-consuming and I still have a
few  do other things yes, I definitely thank you
for watching I hope
the last week and a half have been fun
following the videos here yes and I think we'll see each other
soon with other content on my
channel or via deep chess yes have a nice
day and
bye